Yes, thank you all for coming. Now, it's time to
begin, everyone, and we will begin the long-awaited Japan Wrap-Up
session. This session is currently being streamed live. Yes, in
Japan, it's probably this morning, so I'm sure many people
are watching that live stream. Thank you very much. Yes.
This session carefully selects especially important points from the many
announcements announced at Microsoft Build 2026 and explains them clearly
in Japanese. Although the time is only 45 minutes, we
hope everyone can take home key points we want everyone
to keep in mind, or tips that will lead to
future considerations.
And above all, for those attending in person, I will
make sure to condense and summarize this report thoroughly as
a business trip report, so I hope you will stay
until the end.
Yes, yes.
Now, let me introduce the flow of this session. First,
as a key update for the entire Build 2026, we
will share the main announcement points. Wait, let's continue. This
time, we'll divide it into three areas.
Yes, experts from Microsoft Japan in each field will explain
the specific details. Yes, and if you have time, I'd
love to accept Q&A from everyone at the venue, so
thank you for your help. Alright, without further ado, we
will begin the first session. Under the title Key-Up Days,
we are pleased to hear from Okazaki, Executive Officer and
General Manager of the Cloud and AI Solutions Business Division
at Microsoft Japan.
Well then, Mr. Okazaki, please.
Yes, yes, hello everyone. Yes, I'm Okazaki from Microsoft. Yes,
everyone, welcome. Yes, thank you for participating in Buildway. Yes,
everyone, have you noticed? Here, at the keynote venue where
Satya did it, do you know today? This is the
closing act. Surprisingly, Japan is the place.
I serve as the closing session for the keynote. I
already think it's all thanks to everyone.
. Thank you very much. Yes. Yes, first of all.
Um.
Build, yes. Overview—yes, I hope I can share it. Yes,
it's different from usual, and here, we're holding it in
a place called Automason.
Well, it's a somewhat warehouse-style building. So, we're holding it,
and it feels kind of like a festival, with an
atmosphere that makes developers happy. Yes, we're holding it, and
with 2,500 customers participating locally, it's like 2,500 people. Even
at 2,500, it's overcapacity. Why, well, compared to last time,
we're doing it in a slightly more condensed form. On
the other hand, online, there are people with over 150,000
yen, right?
It looks just like the one you watched.
Thank you.
Alright, then I think we'll get right into the contents.
Yes, this time, well, the main topic of Build Yes
is... Yes, how, yes, how can we create an ecosystem
utilizing frontier AI or agents? Well, that's the key message.
Well, from the developer's perspective and from many of you,
it's about what possibilities there are, and what kind of
support Microsoft can provide. Yes, from the developer's perspective, yes.
Yes, big. Yes,
I spoke in order from four different groups. Yes, from
the infrastructure layer, to the model context tool layer, and
the gent-time developer tool, I'm talking about it from that
perspective. Yes, it's just as I thought.
Because it's all developers. Well, I like these things freely.
While combining these elements, to actually implement enterprise systems, well,
it is important to make solid use of our own
data and secure it.
Execute safely. Well, that's after that. It's important to keep
meeting them. Well, we discussed how to make that happen.
So, first of all. Regarding infrastructure, well, first of all,
what Satya said was...
Performance equals tokens. Yes, I can break it. It's written
in the form of 'Watt to Zaler,' and it's really
important to see how efficiently you can execute with tokens
that deliver the same performance. Well, that's why I'll talk
about it.
And recently, I think many people have experienced this: the
fees for using the distant area are steadily rising. Well,
it's just about managing that properly and skillfully while executing
the performance we want with the right cost negotiation. Well,
the message from E-Key is that it's necessary to balance
these things.
Yes. To make that possible. Yes, the microphone software is.
Well, yes, we're driving innovation across both edge and cloud
platforms.
First, regarding the side of one edge, yes, in the
form of arm-metered intelligence, well, how much of the edge
side? Yes, on the PC side, I announced that by
optimally combining GPUs and NPU, we optimize AI processing on
the edge side to optimize good processing. It's not just
about speeding up the machines, but also about making them
locally foundry. Yes, actually local. E. Luem, huh? We aim
to achieve this by providing technologies that move both the
Windows
side and the edge side. On the other hand, well,
regarding the server side, we continue to innovate. Yes, three
years ago, yes, we announced something called Maia and Cobalt,
and well, they did announce it, and it was called
200. Yes, we have the opportunity to announce the Maia
200 and Cobalt 200, respectively.
Yes, regarding Maia, it is a chipset designed to optimize
AI processing, and for Cobalt, it uses an arm-based architecture,
such as agent applications. Yes, we are optimizing those features.
By executing it efficiently. Yes, we are evolving on the
edge and infrastructure sides, focusing on how efficiently you can
execute what you want to do.
Yes, of course, server-sided. Well, it's not like you can
open it just because of infrastructure upgrades. Well, we believe
it's important to process the database layer as well. Yes,
it was originally like Cosmos Davy, very much. Well, we
have
databases like those used on ChatGPT's backend, but well, as
an even newer technology, yes, Azure Horazon David, right? Yes,
let them publish a public bear review. Seriously. Yes, this
is the post-Gresse Escuel that many customers use. It is
an open-source database, and even large-scale OLTP processing can be
supported in a manager-style manner. And on the other hand,
Regarding the data warehouse, we've announced innovations in the fabric
sector, in the form of GPU acceleration and fabric data
warehouses, and that's NVIDIA.
By combining it with accelerated computing, query performance can be
increased by 7 times, and by actually achieving parallel processing
rates, execution can be done very quickly. Yes, on fabric.
Well, if you're running it, you haven't changed the application.
Well, the key point is that it can realize a
high-speed data warehouse.
Yes, the point is, agents are already accessing the database
more and more. Well, it's important to build a database
architecture that can handle such things—a dataware architecture. On the
other hand, you also consider how much you are an
agent or something. The question is whether we can utilize
and operate our own data, and yes, Microsoft is very
important to us. Microsoft IQ Pro. Ah. The concept of
'toform' is the same. Up until now, we
have presented work IQ, public IQ, and foundry IQ, but
yes, in addition, we also presented something called Web IQ.
Well, to put it simply, yes, AI processing and such.
Well, it's an engine optimized for agent processing, supporting web
grounding. Well, you might have been able to do something
similar before,
but faster, and even more. Huh? Eh, low-cost, right? Well,
WebIQ is about combining processing of such things. Also, well,
it's not just about using Copilot ourselves. They want to
utilize such daywear in their own applications as well. The
key point of the Work iqapi is that it actually
becomes a GA.
That's what I think.
Also, when it comes to implementing agents, we believe that
the key theme is whether to carry out the work
safely and securely. Yes, you also spoke on how to
use OpenClaw and gave a presentation. Well, OpenClaw is really
convenient, and since you can handle all the processes that
could be done on a PC, you can delete files
and such.
When it comes to risk, or when you take action,
you really need to plan. It's scary to use it
in the workplace. Right? Well, in that sense, it's important
to see how to create a safe and secure environment
in a straightforward way for PCs like Windows environments. Well,
if that happens, we announced that newer technologies are easier
to use,
and that's what we called the Microsoft Execution Container. Well,
by combining powerful agent handling with this, you can safely
and securely eliminate it. Exchange. Being able to do this
is also a major point. On the other hand, as
the foundation for running agents on the server side, we
have announced something called a host agent. As you can
imagine, I
think you can understand that agents will need to run
more and more scaling in the future. But the open
agent architecture you created—yes, the things you actually execute. Yeah,
on top of this host agent foundation? So. Huh? Uh:
It can be scaled and executed securely and securely. Well,
the big point is that we also offer that kind
of environment.
It's an intro. Develop.
I've presented a few things regarding par tools, but for
me, Well, I'd like to talk about the git upload
and Copilot update.
Well, to put it simply. Agent-driven, development. Well, it was
centered around agents. Yes, I hope you can think of
it as a desktop application specialized for enterprise development. Yes,
you use multiple agents, and well, people and teams and
agents work together to build it. Well, the platform provides
strong support for those areas, so please feel free to
give it a try. Right. re
Bana. That's how I feel.
Yes, yes, then I see. Well, I want to take
a bit more step back and, in the form of
frontier opportunities, talk not only from the developer's perspective but
also from the frontier customers' perspective — yes, what possible
possibilities are possible. First of all, Microsoft has supported various
AI tools
and agents that you use. Yes, at first, we released
something based on chat. Seriously. Recently, I've been presenting something
called this kind of work. So, while I'm sharing the
tradition of action, the biggest point is that we introduced
something called Autopilot this time. Yes, do you all remember
three years
ago? Microsoft had previously sent a message saying they would
not build Autopilot, but now they are finally running it
autonomously. Well, Autopilot is great, and I can offer it
to everyone. That's how much reality I came to. What.
Say it. I hope you can take this in perspective.
So, about Microsoft's solution and the specific announcement you made.
Yes, this is what we call Microsoft Scout. Yes, the
Japanese demo is available in time, so I hope everyone
can take a look at the screen. Right now, we've
started moving on here, and we're asking for last week's
business trip expense reimbursement.
So, in the cloud they do for M365, they can
simultaneously search for data and local data, and it seems
pretty good. Um, I do the task of finding files.
Then, analyze the files you find. Well, the format is
to take out and remove the content that is actually
included in the expense reimbursement.
Also, the expense reimbursement application I usually use is the
one I usually use, and I find this one, and
I'm trying to use this application to enter this kind
of data. But the point is, is it okay to
do the last thing before you start? The key point
is to ask that question. While we take the lead,
the final decision is made
by the human body, so we designed it to ensure
safety and security. And. Microsoft Scout also uploads files for
you, and the expense settlement is completed—that's what Microsoft Scout
is all about. Most people can probably change their business
trips, so I think many people probably need to handle
this kind of process, so I think many people have
wanted to use it. Yes.
However, I think the evolution of the frontier model plays
a major role in Microsoft Scout's development of Microsoft Scout.
Well, this data is about what it means, but right
now, in 2026, even for long-term processes that require more
than an hour of human input, about 80% of people
will be able to get the correct answer. Well, just
keep evolving with that. . So. But the scalpel I
want to say can't handle those kinds of situations. So,
can I make
everything AI? Where do we and our companies generate value?
That's the big message: it's a single model, and the
evolution of this model isn't just a single model. The
important aspect is that they keep competing and evolving with
various models.
The key point isn't that it depends on the model,
but rather the form that includes that model. Well, things
like harness mechanisms, information sharing with minimal integration and context,
and mechanisms to evaluate how agents are created and whether
agents are functioning properly—we combine these with a system that
continuously monitors our organizational values.
Keep evolving. We evolve our agents into forms that fit
our organization. Well, the idea that we need to create
such a system is what I was passing by throughout
this session. Well, Satya was the last one who suggested
making it together. As you all know, we have supported
over 11,000 models with the Microsoft Fund. Now, here's a
close-up of a representative part. If you go on a
date, you know.
Yes, Cloud Ink Load-in and Microsoft Fundraisal have become supported,
and even the Unstropic model is supported within the fundraiser.
Well, in Japan, that kind of thing isn't quite mainstream
yet, but... Fireworks AI, which can perform open-source optimization processes,
has also become a foundly supported platform. And when you
came this time, you probably thought, 'Huh?' Huh? Microsoft AI:
Well, well, I think the fact that they announced it
on a grand scale was a big message. Yes, the
one
who actually announced the previous story was Mustava. Yes, the
person who originally founded DeepMind and now leads the Mike
Soft AI Promotion Office is presenting this announcement.
Yes, we have released seven different models. Well, for example,
I used Image 2.5 to optimize the image. Yes. Also,
we've been announcing seven models that actually perform highly accurate
character recognition, such as the Transfer Live 1.5. But what
I emphasized most this time was the form of My
Thinking King One. Well, within Microsoft, it runs based on
reasoning base. The most standard model has
also been announced. Right. It has become a form we
were given to us. Depending on the good things—no, even
very open benchmarks—we submit high-level materials, so I think combining
them has increased the options for executing the optimal approach
more effectively. On the other hand, rather than simply relying
on models, we have presented something like frontier tuning that
optimizes the model using our own knowledge.
Well, by utilizing this, yes, we have them learn the
domain knowledge they have. Well, as we keep evolving the
model, we run the optimal processing that best fits our
company.
Also, while evaluating the agent itself. Well, the main announcement
of this build is that we announced a mechanism to
continuously optimize agents. Yes, just now. Danger. I want to
emphasize once again the importance of creating systems that make
AI smarter, whether it's your own knowledge or based on
experience, or by continuously improving your own knowledge, or by
making agents increasingly effective. Finally, yes. Well, for the remaining
parts, I think I'd like to make an announcement on
the security side. Yes, regarding security. Yes, how to leverage
AI to enhance security.
The message is about how to refine the process and
how to strengthen security for handling AI. Security With made
a major announcement regarding AI, and yes, it's the m-dash
that makes a big announcement. Yes, this is, well, I
think there are various security attacks, and we have announced
mechanisms to maintain such risk vulnerabilities and support our customers.
However, the mechanism itself is that the key point is
using four models. By combining models from OpenAce and Anthology,
creating over a hundred agents and building an integrated ecosystem
on this foundation, we have been able to achieve vulnerability
detection at a high level. Well, actually, there's a consumption
indicator called Cyber Gym, right? Is it okay if this
is by far the most popular 88? They also offer
such specifications. Well, in fact, running with this combination is
more effective than running with a single model. Um, being
able to deliver results is similar to the benchmark I
have shown here. And also,
since it's already possible to use it, let's just do
it. Well, lately it's definitely the agent. Well, is that
AI-powered threat really okay? Cases where people get asked that
question are increasing a lot. That's what I think. So,
if you're interested, I hope you'll reach out to our
members. On the other hand,
these are the numbers within Microsoft—the number of agents hasn't
changed, but the number of agents has been steadily increasing.
Recently, there are more than twice as many agents. The
key point is how to manage the organization where the
individual and the agent merge. Well, as the number of
agents keeps increasing, how to
complete them is really important. Right. This is a key
point. To make that happen, as you all know, we
have already announced something called Agent 365. However, the key
point I announced this time was that the key point
was that we have introduced Agent 3654 Local Agent, which
allows us to manage agents operating locally.
Well, for example, OpenPro runs on PCs, like PCs in
our hallway, so it would be problematic if employees could
enter without permission and expose them to risk. So, we
need to properly detect such things and reduce risks by
treating them as important corporate assets. Well, this service is
designed to make those things possible. And on the other
hand,
No, no, I'm not just an agent who works on
MycoSoft. I think the mindset of developers is to widely
incorporate good agents and create products using various technologies. Well,
to support that, by combining something called the Agent 365
SDK, you can create agents in any kind of environment.
Well, um, you can really control it properly on the
control plane. Say it. Since these areas are important, I
hope you will consider utilizing these kinds of things. Lastly,
I hope you can enter the new
frontier category. Well, if you go to the heartfelt message
of 'Beyond the Frontier,' yes, I have announced two main
ones. Well, one of them is a microphone soft discovery.
Well, well, well, I did present it two years ago,
and it was
actually a research exploration type. Um, maybe it's that kind
of survey. We have developed excellent services optimized for those
areas, such as drug discovery or chemical substances. The key
point is to apply AI to places that are quite
central to Japanese industry.
Yes, the point is, the answer hasn't been decided yet.
You create hypotheses and repeatedly test them to find the
answer. Well, that's where the optimization is made. Well, actually,
it will come up after this. Well, well, our excellent
quantum chips have actually been put to use in some
places. 2000 more to go. Yes, in 2029, well, well.
We have announced that it will become a reality, so
I hope you will make use of it. Uh, this
one is also a GA (ga) version. Wait, is it
possible for everyone to make use of it? Well, I've
included the screen, so I won't be able to explain
it in time, so I hope you'll check it out
later.
Yes, that's the last one. Well, I've been presenting the
evolution of infrastructure, but I think even more difficult challenges
will emerge going forward. Well, in that sense, Microsoft is
putting a lot of effort into quantum computing.
Yes, this place called Myura Na 2—well, it was a
one-day event the other day, which was once a hot
topic, so I released that two. Well, in reality, by
further improving reliability, we are achieving the ability to minimize
error rates. Yes, these are also in a form that
cannot be offered in 2029. Yes, Microsoft is doing their
best. Huh? Huh? I hope you can look forward to
it. Yes, yes,
yes, that's what I mean. Um, I want to pass
the baton to the next 'yes, yes' presenter. Yes, Mom,
thank you for your support.
Yes. This is Okawa from Microsoft Japan. Um, from this
time onward, I hope to talk about the local part
of Windows and developer tools.
This time, starting with Windows, I asked, 'Why does Microsoft
update Windows so often?' I was asked, but I think
this is the message that Windows is an environment for
developers, and that we'll keep growing it more and more.
Not just Windows app developers, but cloud developers too.
Including that, I think we will evolve the development environment
accordingly. So, to start by first, this is about unmade
intelligence. It's intelligence that operates locally. Well, it's been around
here as expected. I think some of you must
find token spending tough, but you can still run LLM
locally. Well, that's the kind of place it is. That's
the part where we'll keep going. Since it's compatible with
GPMPW, I skipped a bit and this time, this one
has come out—the Surface ARTIC Spark Rib Box. I want
this, you know, this one, the GPU, the ARTICS, the
GPU, and the CPU for the Arm Artict, all come
together as a set, and so, It has 128GB of
unified memory, so I guess this model, probably around 120
billion, will be able to run it. That means I'm
really looking forward to it too. So, why is such
a local AI important? Well, there are various reasons. Right?
P. There are challenges with livasy security. There are people
who want environments with low latency, and there are various
options, but already, there are many companies that use this
local model to create excellent app shares. It's about
why we should do it together. Of course, Microsoft is
also local. We implement various functions using models. We've implemented
office features and such. Well, I think it's about working
together on these kinds of things. Yes. So, when
you implement this, you get this environment found-ray. On. This
is Window. Recently, there are several layers. The first is
Windows AIPs. This is a typical local AI scenario. Here,
you can access AI keys just by calling the API.
This is the founder-local area. I'll talk about this later,
but we provide that common open-source model—an environment for running
locally. And when it comes to wanting to run my
own unique model, Windows Mail comes up. . Yes,
this time. Well, in addition to NPU, GPU will also
be usable, so I think this is a pretty important
point. Yes, yes, so we'll keep going. It's the Windows
AI API. This is the newly added feature. Well, the
voice recognition feature, and the structure output of Python, this
is the latest update. Furthermore, it can now be used
with GPU and CPU. There's something listed here. Well, for
example, you can summarize the text, or apply a
roller to Faisilica, and so on. Well, you can do
that too. U. It's starting to get worse. That's how
it works. I ended up making too many materials. I'll
keep skipping Foundry Local. Foundry Local. Yes, yes, this is
it. Yes, it's about running an open-source model locally. It
creates an environment. Well, this is it. Download the necessary
model from that Foundationary local and download it locally. And
also, you can call it via API, so let's talk
about it.
There is a room. Wind.
Uzuemuel, this is also a pretty convenient point. Your application
is located in 1-chome, but you can do it from
your own application. For this Windows ML layer, well, well.
By accessing through programs, you can access the hardware layers
beneath us—Intel, AMD, Qualcomm, NV—various hardware types. Windows is used,
but by absorbing the differences in each layer, you can
run models and make inferences about the local ML. Well,
here's how it goes.
Provided as an environment for una.
We are doing so. Yes.
Also, today and this time, I thought it might be
quite a hot topic, so I added it. This web
NN has been mentioned here that it can now run
in this browser, so I hope you will make use
of this as well. Yes. Um, and this MXC will
be coming soon. Since Mr. Nitta will be talking, I'll
skip the topic for a bit.
And from here, for developers, there's that convenient point. I'd
like to highlight a few of them. Windows, you know,
Developer Configurations, this feature has
been released, and there are two options: Dev Configuration Winget
and Double SL Comfort. This is the development environment. When
I move to another machine, installing the tools I use
can take quite a while. Right. But. Some of you
might find it annoying or even turn it into a
script, but here's the point: you set it as a
definition file and then burn it into your environment, so
you can install it all at once. Well, this kind
of feature that makes setting up development environments more convenient
has come out. Also, the Windows 3 654 developer—this is
a machine that runs in the cloud. It's a machine
that runs in the cloud, with 32 VCUs, a massive
128GB of memory, and 2 terabytes of storage.
And apparently, there are GP installation environments too. Well, if
you buy a development environment, if you buy it for
a company, it probably becomes a fixed asset. You have
to depreciate. Well, you know, they'll probably depreciate it over
five years, right? The environment developers use is on the
cloud, with those variable costs, right? You can use this
Operax. I think this is quite a benefit. And on
top of that, you can use some language models on
this
cloud PC. U. That's how it is. That's how it
works. Well, that's how it goes. Connecting local devices and
cloud PCs. The tasks you do on the cloud PC
side are... Just monitor from your local device and give
instructions.
Things like that.
Actually, it's possible. So, this is it. It's a WSL
container.
I think you can still use double SL before, but
now you can use it as a container and execute
it. So, the commands are called Double SA and Double
SLC, and these will be released soon. Compared to that
double SL, it's a bit lighter,
and you can run Linux containers on Windows in a
lighter environment, which is a convenient point. Thoughts. Anyway. So,
here's the development skill for developing Windows apps. This is
the terminal for developing Windows apps. Regarding the terminal, this
is the Incegen terminal. It seems
the city administration will be integrated into the terminal. While
operating that terminal, I got some kind of error. Nowadays,
I think you'd probably copy the error or message and
ask the LLM for the answer, but what exactly is
this error? This terminal is now available in an integrated
way from above. Well, that's how it looks. Wait. I
think this will also be a convenient feature. Next, about
Debtrax, the knife for software companies that sharpens well, probably
evolving into a central control system for software factories. I
think everyone is watching this process now. So, the Ritter
Copilot update has been released. This is it. Well, until
now, there have been people using CLI and VS code,
and I think some people were using it in that
browser, but with the new desktop app for Windows, well,
that's the new desktop app that came out. . Um,
this is how it looks. Well, in that repository base,
there's that list on the left side. Then, based on
the repository, you open chat sessions and proceed with that
process. Alright, and with
this, I think the most interesting thing I found was
this Canvas extension. Sorry for the small handwriting. It's down
there. It's called Create Canvas. You say, 'Please create a
canvas application,' give instructions, and inside, you can use GitHub
Copilot to make a signboard application, and if you ask
me to make a signboard application, it will create a
signboard or canvas for you. So, this app, this canvas
app, is stored in my own repository. Why can you
share this signboard with others who share the same repository,
and the agent can do the same, this is called
the canvas application data? Share it. This is the kind
of form that allows agents and humans to form more
convenient teams, so I guess this is the kind of
feature that has emerged. And for the runtime
part, it's a sandbox. Well, these days, well, several isolation
layers are implemented. Well, you can run directly, create containers
per session, or do it in a sandbox managed by
the OS. And here's the one thing I want to
do. Automate tasks you perform every
day. Automation. Section. That's the amount. Well, it's a bit
of a small font, but if you define the code
review at what time every day as automation means it's
automatically done every morning, for example. It will carry it
out. So, this is it. That automation is also properly
implemented in the cloud. It's running on Recurve. Why is
that repository operation? I didn't know notifications would come to
my smartphone too. Then, when I checked the code review
results on my smartphone app during my morning commute and
said something
was off, I went through the loop. You can also
assign tasks like assigning it to one lap of Copilot.
And it's the same with that desktop app too. Like.
You can assign and make a loop, have them check
it out, and then the agent
will automatically resolve the issue. Well, that's how it is—the
workflow is set up. And of course, when doing code
reviews, within this same Copilot app, you can split the
pane, review the code, and then automatically merge the code,
and you can now have agents do it.
So, is this what that past history was? I think
that's quite common, but well, there are commands for doing
that too. Well, in this way, until now, the world
was where
people would ask coding agents to assist them, and the
coding agents would handle the work beyond that. But from
now on, there will be an agent team. There are
humans there too. So, that's the part. Everyone. That's what
I thought. I think AI agents are development teams that
collaborate and work together to pursue a single outcome. So,
I think there are people who want to use this
in that program. So, this time we launched the Copilot
SDK, which is the GA. So, I hope everyone will
definitely use it. Yes, regarding the development environment, it supports
six languages right now. Yes, the fact that it was
newly added with a Jabba and a final piece is
a key point. Huh? Huh? So, you see.
This Copilot SDK includes the class platform and sound box
functions, so this one too, well, when separating security and
running agents, it becomes a pretty important point, so I
recommend giving it a try. This is the separation of
sessions, well, it's a definition file, like where you can
access it—something like this.
Yes. In that sense, I define it.
It will be so. Yes.
So, the point is, you can use it in various
environments. The key point is that it can be used
on local machines, cloud points, and well, well, well, it's
exactly that it can be used in environments disconnected from
the network. The final message is to ask them to
use it in various places. Why has it evolved from
the Copilot coding agent for guitars to the Copilot cli
Copilot SDK? Well, you can use any kind of machine—locally
or in the cloud. So, for everyone like Windows, this
time we've evolved and can develop in the environment they
like.
Why is that? I hope you enjoy coding and developing
applications in environments you like. Yes, next time, regarding the
cloud AI part with Mr. Nitta.
Right. I hope you can share that story. Yes.
Yes, everyone, hello. I am a reaper of Microsoft Japan
solution engineers. Well, from my side, I'd like to share
a brief update about the agent. Yes, I think I
mentioned this diagram earlier in the context of the Frontier
developer, but I'd like to introduce the parts outlined in
red here, which are a bit short of that time.
Yes, first of all. Um, from below. I'm sorry. I'd
like to start from the bottom of this diagram. Yes,
first, let's talk about the context. Yes. It was announced
in today's session, and in the form of IQ serverless
by the fund, the so-called 'good serverless AI search service'
was announced in a public preview. So, originally.
Yes, it's AI search. The current system, which used to
be about sizing capacity in this way, is the way
it used to be, but well, with serverless usage, it
can be used vigorously at zero scale, so I think
it's become very user-friendly. Right now, it's a developer-tier area,
so I think you can use it for a trial
period, so if you're interested, please give it a try.
We hope you will receive it.
Yes, continuing on, there's the Microsoft Execution Container, which has
appeared several times before, and it's called the Leftt MXC.
Well, yes, in keynotes, you can run it with OpenClaw
Windows. Also, the Copaote SDK cross that was just shown.
TOM'S and Box are also being realized with this technology,
but from my perspective, the key points are a bit
technical—well, well, lately, there have been quite a few
OS layers. —. I think the last part is quite
used, but mxc also implements the native binary for that
OS at the end, and the SDK for the interface
that implements that native binary is implemented as a type
script. And since this is publicly available on Github, the
content is still there. Of course, this is a preview
of that service, but I definitely want to be interested.
If so, please take a look. Yes.
Yes. Now, I'd like to move on to observability, but
before we get into the specific service, I'd like to
share some comments from NTT DATA. Now, let's talk about
the features I'm about to introduce. In fact, NTT Data
has been conducting verification during the private preview stage. So,
within NTT DATA's initiative called Smart Air Agent, well, the
control play of that foundry this time... Middle. and among
them, there were comments saying there is a very powerful
enterprise-grade system that can accelerate smart air agent initiatives, and
well, during this Microsoft Build event, Well, as an employee,
I am truly delighted to receive comments like this. Now,
the observation part I'm about to introduce is probably
a demo like this, and you really need to see
the screen in person. Wah. Huh? A difficult spot. I
think there might be some of that, so I hope
you can just get a glimpse of the image. So,
I'd like to introduce a quick slide with a few
slides. First, the first is the New Evaluation Capability,
which is an extension of the evaluation functions that existed
until now. When evaluating agents, Not just single interactions, but
also multi-turn evaluations that include all conversational exchanges, or the
agent's
Yes, you look at definitions, simulate the multi-tan conversation, and
give it a good evaluation. Also, I create datasets from
existing trace data. Yes, and also, regarding continuous evaluation, to
improve accuracy, we of course evaluate everything, but since we
can't evaluate everything this way, we have a function that
properly samples and evaluates the system. Yes, yes, it has
been developed. This is a public preview. Huh? Well, I've
already
tried it out, but I think it might work. From
here, the private preview feature appears, and first, the Rubric
Evaluator feature is introduced. Until now, it was fundraising. When
evaluating custom items, users created custom evaluators and evaluated them.
This rubric valuer automatically generates custom evaluators based on agent
definitions, and based on this, you can evaluate the custom
by providing a review. Value. Machine. making it easier to
make
I wonder if it happened? That's what I think.
And the other is mainly using the rubric evaluator mentioned
earlier. This agent, called the Optimizer, has appeared. So, this
is a function of an optimizer that uses agents in
a loop to set specific thresholds and meet those thresholds
in a way that is better than possible. Well, it's
like models, tools, skills, and so on.
Yes, we experiment with prompts and things like that. Yes,
the loop keeps spinning and optimizing the process more and
more. So, well, for those who did machine learning, there
were usually several methods for hyperpanameter tuning, like candycates, and
I think they selected the most accurate method, but the
image was exactly the same. Yes, personally, I think it's
fine. Well. Optimizers in that kind of way are used
on that fundraiser for private
It appears in the preview section.
Also, there are things called 'R-O'4 Agents,' which are designed
to achieve a return on investment. Well, it's a feature
that visualizes the cost of tokens and the cost of
valuation to the top of the tool called, links the
business value of those users to the actual cost-effectiveness, and
makes even more visible that this is actually cost-effective. This
is also a feature for the Price. Be. It's available
in the preview, and the Agent Optimizer I
just introduced and R-5 Agent are expected to be in
public preview soon, so I think you can try them
out right away. Now, starting with the 'Observability' feature I
introduced this time, there are also guardrails on the foundry.
Various features including security have been introduced, so this session
is definitely worth your attention. Well, including what was recorded.
Look. I hope you can take your leave. Now, let's
continue with the section on cloud platform data, Gakugu-san.
Hello everyone. This is Yamamoto from Microsoft. Yes, from me,
yes. Just three main updates—okay, I'll introduce them, so just
remember these three before you leave. One is the AI
data center, another is the modernization of the Okay Guitar
Co-Pilot, and the third is the Layfin. First, the first
point.
From the AI data center. What made me realize again
through this build is that it's not just the AI
model itself, but the infrastructure that supports it is crucial.
In the past year and a half, Microsoft has expanded
data center capacity comparable to the first decade of the
Azure era.
This is like Copilot that you all use, or when
you use AI tools, well, sessions start up, right? And
in each session, container-like things pop up one after another.
Then, by doing that, you perform the proper processing and
respond to the user. Yes, it does it immediately. So,
yes, infrastructure equipped with good capacity GP for data centers
becomes extremely important, and for that, we need to expand
data centers. Ah. Yes, yes, this was also a key
note for Satya, and yes, yes, we have also begun
construction of an AI-dedicated data center called Fairwater. And when
we keep expanding our data centers like this, it's not
that we're expanding without thinking—there are principles. While adhering to
policies like not raising local electricity bills and circulating water
to reduce actual consumption to zero, we are implementing the
cloud on a global scale in a very sustainable way.
We are working to provide the power of these efforts.
And the ones running in those data centers are in-house
developed chips like Mayer and Cobalt, which were from Okazaki
earlier. So, for us, I think Microsoft's tools are good
because they deliver value to everyone through a full stack
of data centers, chips, OS, and developer tools. Next are
Guitar of Co, Pilot, and Modernization.
This is not a GA but rather a feature extension,
but what I felt during the session with this build
was that the Copilot modernization of the guitar section is
about to change the very way modernization progresses. I've been
at Microsoft for eight years, and I've supported many customers
with their commitment to quality. It's just a simple intention
or a rehost.
So, yes. There are a lot of customers who end
up finishing. Many customers say modernization is not progressing smoothly.
Come and see. Orima.
So, the reason modernization hasn't progressed is that it's difficult
to coordinate between the development team, infrastructure team, and IT
team. To modernize, a broad understanding of applications, infrastructure, and
governance operations is required.
With the addition of the Guitar Department's Copilot, we can
now provide various forms of support, allowing the development and
IT teams to advance modernization on the same foundation. This
is the actual modernization screen of that guitar department, Copied.
On my VS code, I started the VS code in
the folder where the source code is.
We are about to launch the guitar onaization extension. This
is a Java application, but we conducted an assessment. Well,
it depends on the scale, but it's about 20 minutes.
The results of the assessment will be released. How to
migrate to the cloud? What needs to be changed to
migrate to Perth?
Huh? You can see that right away.
.
So, what's the biggest change in this announcement is on
this screen. Hey, especially on the right side, I want
you to look at the rulebook, command center, and the
biggest part is expanding supported scenarios. It's the mainframe marked
in red. Yes. I also spoke with some customers, and
they still run with mainframe spills.
Application.
That's what I've heard. In fact, yes, it was like
this. Yes, with a partner.
We have also received feedback from customers on the modernization
of the guitar club Copilot. We have also experienced this
modernization with Japanese partners such as Hitachi and NTT Data,
so we hope to talk with you again when we
return to Japan. This is the third and last one.
This is the layfin.
So, in this era of AI, I think it's become
this easy for everyone to make apps and even mockups.
But it's tough to bring that to the production level
and even the production level. So, what makes it difficult
is that building the backend involves authentication, good operations, governance,
and so
on—it's extremely challenging. This Layfin is provided by AI and
Microsoft. Huh? This project aims to use the power of
fabric to enable applications at a production level that can
be used, including the backend. This was announced as a
public preview. I have a quick video, so let's check
it out.
U.
I went too far. Please wait a moment.
Don't play the video.
Thank you, everyone.
We have them.
Sorry, um, um, I wanted to show it at the
end, but time ran out all at once. Thank you
very much.
I did. Thank you.
Thank you very much. I want to finish in just
one minute of 'Kkukkuku'. Regarding that Q&A, I hope to
have plenty of fun during the Japan dinner afterward, and
I hope to ask for your help there.
Yes, and also, um, you have to ask for this,
and yes, this is the recap. The event is being
planned by a Japanese person, so there will be an
announcement later, but I really hope you'll join us. Please
share this with other members, and um, last minute, yes,
here is the link to that survey. Um, I think
you'll share
the link later, so please give me feedback. Um, can
we continue this session? How about that? That depends on
everyone, so I hope you'll read that part and leave
it to me. Also, well, next time, okay. There's Ignite
in November, and there will be another build next year,
so I'm looking forward to seeing you all again. Thank
you very much.
I did.